you know that is something to be said
for watching your show live as it airs
I'm not waiting for the blu-ray to come
out or come out of Netflix you to review
it early so it was fun arrow season 3
and just letting you know there's a
spoiler warning there's going to be some
spoilers for arrow season 3 it's just
hard to talk about something like this
like 20-something odd episodes of a show
and not touch on some of the spoilers so
watch it you're risk you've been warned
so an arrow season 3 they go some
direction just one of those shows this
season they were like all right we gotta
up the ante we got to show what all of
our Queens made ever really got a
hinamori live which most people who
watch season 2 you're like yeah that's
what they did in season 2 with
Deathstroke although it can make you
kind of nervous because you're like I
hope you don't go in a direction that's
so new that it's like it's not even
arrow anymore when this season started
out I was like everything feels like a
well-oiled machine and I don't like that
now you look at last season Oliver Queen
lost his entire family fortune his mom
died his sister left however when you
see them while fighting crime or like
everyone's just really good at what they
do
Roy Harper has his red arrow suit he's
all arsenal and he's like a badass now
how long did you train for that [ __ ] he
just shows up he's a pop hop out how
loss of my mind all right seeing the
next injustice game oh my god does
everything felt too clean and I really
didn't like that and the end of last
season they go into directioner I was
like are you doing this for season 3 I
don't know if I like that either because
what we knew is Oliver Queen was on this
island for five years not anymore
we find out he went to Hong Kong I guess
even in one episode in here he goes back
to Starling city right there I just
don't like that kind of [ __ ] I like him
being on an island Castaway style his
hairs all Long's beards all nappy and he
was like I'm gonna go to whale but good
this was the season where I was like
alright the flashbacks no longer
interest me in fact if they do away with
the flashbacks next season I just won't
miss it that's a lie I'll totally miss
it but I want them to do something else
bring them back to the island and make
him like you know stranded there and
[ __ ] come over right out the gate they
killed Sara as Black Canary which I was
like oh my god that's really cool then
you realize they're gonna make Laurel
Black Canary and you're like oh my god I
don't know if I'd want that but all in
all the main thing going down is Ra's al
Ghul wants Oliver Queen to take his
blood basically this is what you need to
know about Oliver Queen in the show era
Oliver Queen is Bruce Wayne straight up
whatever legal logistics are involved in
it pointing
they can't have bruce wayne's so it's
Oliver Queen but everything I see in
here with him and Ra's al Ghul I saw in
Batman animated series Ra's al Ghul
wants Oliver Queen to take his mantle
and he does this after the mid-season
finale was crazy
oh my god like he fights Ross how cool
Ross stabs him and pushes him over a
cliff I was like oh [ __ ] he's dead after
the mid-season finale were like is he a
lie you know he's gonna be alive but
still I bit my nails and it turns out
he's alive because katana right if you
remember my Suicide Squad videos like
others that one check I don't know much
about her tours that she was right under
my nose because she's the girl in arrow
and she brings him back but you're like
is it how the hell did he live through
that one of my friends was like well the
cult can do it you know it can you know
it can help you live through a wound I
just sent him a picture of that [ __ ] and
I was like oh who knew if it was cold
outside he could live through that no
not really the stab the concerned me it
was the fall or the mix of both however
the dude they have playing Ra's al Ghul
at first I was like I don't know if I
buy you as Ra's al Ghul man but then by
the end I totally liked him and because
they change his hair at first he has
like the hair that goes forward and I'm
like you just looked like some dude in a
robe when his hairs all back he looks
all villainous I'm like now we're
talking now we are talking and I liked
him and even at a point you don't know
if Oliver Queen is actually taking his
side on this [ __ ] and at a point he
screws over his friends he screws over
everyone he knows and cares about he's
just like no I'm the new Ra's al Ghul
now or I'm going to be he was working
with Malcolm Merlyn I actually like that
arc also Malcolm merlyn's like one of my
favorite characters in the show period
and I'm okay with him teaming up with
Oliver Queen because [ __ ] bowser's
teamed up with Mario out of porn so did
wooden villains team up with heroes I'm
cool with it I'm not buying Thea queen
though I mean she hung out with Malcolm
Merlyn for a summer now she's a complete
badass took Oliver Queen how long to
become a badass she kicks it with this
guy for a summer now it's like karate
kids like a wax on wax off two months
later boom you're a master however WB is
terrible at spoilers actually the worst
all of their next time on arrow it shows
what I don't want to see like the
previews for the season finale showed
Oliver Queen spoiler alert right here
you don't know if he's good you don't
know if he's bad at me no you imagine he
is kind of good but he's done some dick
moves it shows him in the previous four
this
finale go my name is Oliver Queen - Ra's
al Ghul you're like alright well [ __ ]
that cats out of the bag you're a good
guy and even I'm flash a week prior it
showed Oliver Queen in his black garb
and help flash he's like yeah I'm trying
something new hey I need your help with
something I'm like okay so he is
officially a good guy now glad I know
that before I'm actually supposed to
know that
again anyone's gonna know it's like
wolves called arrows so they're not
gonna actually flip him bad idiot I'm
just saying good entertainment makes me
forget that shit's like maybe Oliver
Queen did die on the cliff maybe he did
turn bad in this season so when you ruin
the suspense in the next time previews
or the flash episode it makes me
irritated what can I say guys in the end
arrow season 3 actually is a big
departure from where they were going
before before it was like Oliver Queen
and the select few people who actually
knew what he did and I liked those
seasons more because they do concentrate
on Oliver Queen because there are just a
select few people who know what he does
now there's a bunch of heroes in this
show and it runs the risk of being too
crowded for my tastes it's not too
apparent yet in this season it's just a
fear I have for season four so I hope
that I in that out next season but I
love Brandon Roth as Adam I really like
to do they got to play Ra's al Ghul I
continue to love Diggle I love the
supporting cast that it looks like they
listen to the fans the characters that
fans weren't really fond of they're gone
now
I have a feeling making Thea queen of
heroes just gonna irritate the [ __ ] out
of me and I'll talk about that next year
I guess I like the personal trial over
all that Oliver Queen had to go through
in this season I can say this I guess
I'm the optimist because there were a
lot of for this show this season of the
show divided fans or some people who
loved it some people who hated it and I
hate it when people sit back they're
like well I understand both those points
of view it's like no give a definitive
state but I do understand both points of
view the show went some new directions
this season it was necessary for Oliver
Queen's character and I like that but I
could see how it a lien Aidid some other
fans because it's such a new directions
like is this still arrow or is it like
the arrow League or some [ __ ] I still
had some great moments this season some
excellent moments overall still an
enjoyable show but it is slipping and I
don't want to see them slip so much to
where it's like oh now you're just down
to that show I don't watch anymore no
regrets watching season three but
they're gonna watch some stuff in season
4 Matt you got to put it back on course
focus up keep it arrow keep Oliver
Queen's goals and motivations and focus
right guys so arrow season 3 have you
seen it what did you think about it how
does it compare to the other two seasons
for you whatever you think comment
let me know and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more